[Musique]
les sénateurs agissent
lutter contre la manipulation des
compétitions sportives
1450 milliards d'euros c'est le chiffre
d'affaires mondiale de l'industrie des
paris sportifs pour l'année 2021 dont
220 milliards d'euros pour le continent
européen plus de la moitié de ce chiffre
d'affaires concerne le football
ces énormes profits suscitent la
convoitise des réseaux de criminalité
organisés dans ce contexte le Sénat a
autorisé le 26 octobre 2022 la
ratification de la Convention du Conseil
de l'Europe sur la manipulation de
compétitions sportives dite convention
de ma Colin
c'est ce qu'avait recommandé sa
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées le
rapporteur André valligny a rappelé que
les recettes criminelles mondiales
provenant des paris truqués étaient
estimés par Europole à 120 millions
d'euros pour la seule année 2020 au-delà
des considérations économiques le
phénomène porte également atteinte à
l'intégrité des compétitions sportives à
l'approche de deux événements sportifs
majeurs qui seront organisés en France
la Coupe du monde de rugby et les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques la
ratification de cette convention est
essentielle pour protéger l'intégrité
des compétitions mais aussi des sportifs
qui participeront la Commission a donc
invité le gouvernement à inscrire au
plus vite la convention de ma Colin à
l'ordre du jour de l'Assemblée nationale
pour permettre sa ratification
il ne faut pas attendre qu'un accord se
dégage au sein de l'Union européenne sur
une adhésion commune des États membres
si le droit français est d'ores et déjà
conforme aux exigences posées par la
Convention la commission des affaires
étrangères et de la défense du Sénat
considère qu'il est nécessaire d'aller
encore plus loin ainsi elle préconise la
création d'un délit d'initié sportif
elle souhaite aussi la création d'un
dispositif de lanceur d'alerte
spécifique elle plaide en outre pour un
blocage des flux financiers entre les
opérateurs de paris illégaux et les
consommateurs et se prononcent en faveur
de la dissolution des personnes morales
pour les délits de corruption sportive
enfin la Commission insiste pour que la
sensibilisation des sportifs ainsi que
la formation aux outils existants dans
ce domaine soit renforcé
pour en savoir plus consultez le rapport
de la commission des affaires étrangères
et de la défense du Sénat
[Musique]